>> A BRAND-NEW SUPREME COURT
SHOWDOWN BREWING ON CAPITOL
HILL.
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS KICKING
OFF TODAY FOR JUDGE KETANJI
BROWN JACKSON.
REPUBLICANS PROMISING TO ASK
TOUGH QUESTIONS, BUT SAY THEY
WON'T TURN THE HEARING INTO A
SMEAR CAMPAIGN LIKE DEMOCRATS
HAVE.
>> THIS WILL NOT BE A POLITICAL
CIRCUS.
THIS WILL NOT BE THE KIND OF
CHARACTER SMEAR THAT SADLY OUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES HAVE
GOTTEN VERY GOOD AT.
>> THE MOST NOMINEE WAS
SUBJECTED TO ACCUSATIONS ABOUT
THAT UNFILTERED BIGOTRY.
>> NO REPUBLICAN SENATOR IS
GOING TO UNLEASH ON YOU AND
ATTACK ABOUT YOUR CHARACTER WHEN
THE HEARING IS VIRTUALLY OVER.
NONE OF US, I HOPE, HAVE BEEN
SITTING ON INFORMATION ABOUT YOU
AS A PERSON FOR WEEKS OR MONTHS.
>> SOME OF THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA
ARE GIVING THE NOMINEE COVER
BEFORE THE HEARING EVEN STARTS.
>> WHAT JOSH HAWLEY IS DOING
WHEN HE TRIES TO DO THIS, HE'S
TRYING TO GET HER KILLED.
TRYING TO GET VIOLENCE DONE
AGAINST A SUPREME COURT NOMINEE.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU KNOW THAT GUY, DON'T YOU?
>> YEAH, HE'S BEEN ON MY SHOW.
HE DISCOVERED THE MORE EXTREME
YOU BECOME, THE MORE YOU END UP
ON OUR SHOW.
>> THE REPUBLICANS GET A NAIL
EITHER WAY, RIGHT?
THEY EITHER FIGHT THE FIGHT
DEMOCRATS HAVE FOUGHT, WHICH
TAKES ALL THEIR ABILITY TO STAY
MAD ABOUT THE KAVANAUGH HEARING
AND THE MORAL GROUND AWAY THEY
BELIEVE THEY HAVE.
IF THEY DO A REGULAR HEARING,
THIS IS JUST A PROGRESSIVE ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I WOULD SAY THAT -- I WOULD GO
WITH THAT DIRECTION.
I WOULD SAY KEEP YOU POWDER DRY
BECAUSE YOU'RE REPLACING AN L
WITH AN L, RIGHT?
THIS IS A PUSH.
TRUE, SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE PERSON.
BUT THE FACT IS, THEY LOST A
LIBERAL, THEY ARE GOING TO GET
LIBERAL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LOSE YOUR
MIND.
HOWEVER, YOU WILL BE REMINDED
HOW DIFFERENT REPUBLICANS ARE.
THEY AREN'T AS DISGUSTING AND
VICIOUS IN THESE SETTINGS.
WHEN A DEMOCRAT RUNS THIS, IT
BECOMES A WITCH TRIAL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
REPUBLICANS A LITTLE BIT
TOUGHER.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO OBSESS.
IF THEY OBSESS OVER CRITICAL
RACE TRAINING --
>> THEORY.
>> WHATEVER, JESSICA.
>> I'LL SAY WHATEVER TOO --
>> ANYWAY -- THE MEDIA IS GOING
TO GALVANIZE THAT WEAPON, WHICH
IS DEMONIZATION THROUGH RACIAL
ACCUSATION.
IF YOU BRING UP CRT, THEY'RE
GOING TO CALL YOU A RACIST.
SPEAKING OF DISGUSTING, I HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE FOR MY HYGIENE.
THERE WAS NO HOT WATER.
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU.
>> I HAVEN'T SHAVED AND I STINK
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T BATHED IN TWO
DAYS.
>> YOU'RE PROUD OF THAT?
>> NO.
I'M DISGUSTED.
>> CLEAN THINGS UP A LITTLE BIT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I SAW MARCIA BLACKBURN VIDEO.
SHE WENT IN ON HER PRETTY QUICK
AND PRETTY HARD ABOUT THINGS
LIKE PARENTAL RIGHTS.
THAT WAS ONE THING SHE BROUGHT
UP.
THE IDEA OF HOW SCHOOLS ARE
TREATED AND WHETHER PARENTS --
PARENTS' RIGHTS.
ONE THING THAT STOOD OUT SHE
VOLUNTEERED TO DEFEND GUANTANAMO
BAY PRISONERS OF WAR.
HER BROTHER IS AN IRAQ WAR
VETERAN.
IT'S NOT SHE'S IMMUNE TO THAT.
HOW DO YOU THINK AMERICANS
SHOULD SEE THAT
>> I THINK AMERICANS KNOW OUR
SYSTEM IS DIFFERENT THAN OTHER
PLACES AND DEFENDANTS GET TO
HAVE A PUBLIC DEFENDER.
THEY GET TO HAVE REPRESENTATION
IN COURT.
AND GITMO DETAINEES WERE GIVEN
THAT AND SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN.
BUT THAT IS OUR SYSTEM.
THAT'S OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
SHE WAS PARTICIPATING IN THE
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE AND I DON'T
KNOW IF SHE WENT DOWN THERE AND
SHE'S TALKING TO HER GITMO
DETAINEE AND DID YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT SUCH AND SUCH.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE THERE
AS APOLLO  -- APOLOGISTS.
WE SAW IN THE KAVANAUGH HEARINGS
AND IN SOME WAYS THE AMY CONEY
BARRETT HEARINGS, THERE WAS A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM AND THE
DEMOCRATS ABSOLUTELY WON IT.
THEY GOT THE GOLD.
THERE'S NO NEED FOR REPUBLICANS
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE ALL
MET WITH HER.
APPARENTLY THEY THINK SHE'S
QUITE CHARMING, VERY WISE.
BUT THIS QUESTION ABOUT -- TWO
QUESTIONS.
ONE, SHE SAYS SHE DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE A JUDICIAL
PHILOSOPHY.
WHAT IS YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL
PHILOSOPHY?
THAT IS ACTUALLY WHAT YOU ARE
THERE TO DO, IS TO INTERPRET THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE SECOND --
>> MARCIA BLACKBURN, YOU'RE ON
TOP OF IT TODAY WITH HER.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY ISs
THERE'S A QUESTION YOU'LL HEAR
REPUBLICANS BRING UP AGAIN AND
AGAIN THE QUESTION OF THE DARK
MONEY GROUP THEY SAY -- DARK
MONEY THAT BASICALLY ENSURED
THAT THE PROGRESSIVES GOT
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON, RATHER
THAN CHILDS AS THE NOMINEE.
>> SHE WAS ON OBAMA'S SHORT
LIST.
PROBABLY GOING TO BE THE THEME
OF THE HEARING.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
SHE'S GOT THE VOTES.
SHE WAS APPROVED TO GO TO THE
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS I THINK
A YEAR AGO, A LITTLE OVER A YEAR
AGO, TWO YEARS AGO.
THREE REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR HER.
RIGHT NOW SHE ONLY NEEDS ALL THE
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR HER.
SO THIS IS AN EASY WIN FOR HER.
THE QUESTION IS -- DANA MADE
REFERENCE TO THIS.
A JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
THAT IS NOT TELLING PEOPLE HOW
YOU WOULD VOTE.
IT IS YOUR INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
IS IT A LIVING DOCUMENT?
THE DEMOCRATS FOR YEARS HAVE
GONE AFTER CONSERVATIVES AND
THEY HAVE SAID THAT, IF YOU HAVE
A CONSERVATIVE JUDICIAL
PHILOSOPHY, THEN YOU'RE NOT
QUALIFIED TO BE ON THE COURT.
SO THE DEMOCRATS HAVE CREATED A
PRECEDENT TO GO AFTER THIS
JUDGE, POTENTIAL JUSTICE.
I THINK MORE IMPORTANT IS HER
RECORD ON CRIME AND SPECIFICALLY
CHILD PORN.
THAT'S SOMETHING I DID A LOT OF
AS A PROSECUTOR.
RIGHT NOW SHE HAS TO EXPLAIN WHY
HER SENTENCES WERE LOWER THAN
THE SENTENCING GUIDELINES.
HERE'S THE STATUTE.
SAYS YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE A
MANDATORY MINIMUM OF FIVE YEARS
OR A MAXIMUM OF 20 YEARS.
SHE VERY OFTEN WENT UNDER THE
REQUIRED SENTENCING GUIDELINE.
THEY SAY THE REASON SHE DID THAT
WAS BECAUSE SHE WAS LOOKING AT
POSSESSION AS OPPOSED TO
RECEIVING.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THERE'S
NO DIFFERENCE IN THE POSSESSION
OF OR RECEIVING OF CHILD PORN.
IF YOU MAKE IT, YOU'RE A DIRT
BAG, FOR SURE.
EXPLAIN TO ME, POTENTIAL
JUSTICE, WHY YOU WENT BELOW
SENTENCING GUIDELINES FOR THE
DIRT BAGS IN OUR SOCIETY.
>> CHILD PORN, JESSICA.
>> TELL US WHY SHE SHOULD BE A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
>> THAT'S A LARGER QUESTION THAN
CHILD PORN SENTENCING GUIDELINES
AND JOSH HAWLEY HAS BEEN BEATING
THAT DRUM.
HE DID AGAIN TODAY.
THERE -- CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS
SAYING THE ATTACKS --
>> SAID SHE HAD TO EXPLAIN WHY
SHE WENT BELOW THE GUIDELINES.
DISINGENUOUS
>> IN THE TITLE OF THE PIECE.
SHE WAS TAKING NOTES ON JOSH
HAWLEY'S POINTS AS HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT CASES HE WANTS TO
KNOW ABOUT.
SHE HAS, ACCORDING TO EVERYBODY
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, HAS
BEEN RECEPTIVE TO ADORING TYPE
QUESTIONS AND THE QUESTIONS --
MAR QUESTIONS ABOUT CRT --
COUPLE OF THINGS I THOUGHT WERE
IMPORTANT ABOUT HER PERSPECTIVE
AND IT WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY DICK
DURBIN, SHE DISCUSS HER JOBS IN
TERMS OF TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY HER DECISION
TAKE IT AND HER EXPERIENCE AS A
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND SHE WOULD BE
THE FIRST ON THE COURT TO HAVE
THAT EXPERIENCE, REALLY FRAMES
HER PERSPECTIVE IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT WAY THAN OTHER PEOPLE
WE HAVE HAD ON THE COURT.
THERE'S A CHART THAT THE
"WASHINGTON POST" CREATED THAT
ALL OF THE QUALITIES THAT
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HAVE,
WHERE THEY WENT TO SCHOOL,
DEBATE -- SHE'S THE ONLY ONE
THAT CHECKS EVERY SINGLE BOX ON
THE CHART.
THAT MAKES HER PRETTY SPECIAL.
>> 6-3 SHE'LL GET IN.
>> WE CAN SAY THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHY DON'T WE JUST SKIP THIS
AND GET -- WE KNOW WHAT THE VOTE
IS GOING T